what has gone well for duckduckgo
and uh how is the business doing in
terms of
what percentage of search do you have
here in the united states how many
people use it every day or month uh
what's the revenue like how many
employees where has the business has
gone to in the last 11 years yeah give
us the update okay decade long update um
in a few words so we are beyond search
now you know we started off as private
search but um our vision is wider
it's uh really to be the easy button for
privacy online so our current
ductaco product app and extension is the
search engine plus all the features you
need to have private browsing so tracker
blocker encryption the mobile app is a
full browser and on desktop you can get
it as your browser extension and your
favorite browsers um and together it
adds up to you know ads not following
you around the internet uh private
search
um you know filter bubble going away
all the benefits you get for privacy so
that's product wise kind of come a long
way
there
we've been growing pretty much
exponentially since we talked about 50
60 percent a year
um and that you know we don't track our
users so we don't have like here's our
maus what we do nowadays is do uh
national surveys understanding how many
people are using don't take go every
month so you literally don't have on
your servers the number of searches that
come in or the number of years numbers
so you just don't disclose it
we don't have users so we don't have any
search histories on duckduckgo um
and so when we survey the us we find um
about 10
of the population uses ducta go
in some way during during the month um
they're not all full-time users and so
when you add up or or they're often
full-time on one like browser like
mobile or desktop and so when you add up
actual search percentages we're between
two and three percent right now the full
kind of search market by uh by volume
how do you make money
we make money hasn't changed in 10 years
uh contextual ads so private search ads
so
on google and the ads that follow you on
the internet those are behavioral ads
they're about you as a person you know
like they're
you search for furniture furniture
follows you around or whatever based on
your interests and demographics and what
they think they know about you on
duckduckgo
you type in furniture you just get
furniture add based on that one yeah
just just that search results page uh
there's no search history um and that's
really it um you know all of our our
money really comes from contextual
advertising
and so if a criminal uh organization or
let's say just a criminal was typing in
you know how to do something horrible in
the world and the fbi came to you or
uh and said hey give us your search logs
give us the ip addresses we know that
this person uses duckduckgo
and they typed in how to build a bomb
and they blew up the oklahoma city
building you don't actually have that
data you don't store that data you
couldn't help the fbi out in that
classic 24 television show instance
correct
yeah so just take a step back we think
privacy is just for mainstream people
wanting to not be manipulated online so
you know 100 we have on the order of
maybe 100 million people across the
world using it so it's definitely for
anyone and everyone um that said yes
we've never received any formal warrant
of any kind uh for search histories
because we don't we don't have any
search histories so if anyone kind of
reach out to us and say hey could you
help us here we just reply look we don't
have any ipa addresses with searches or
anything like that so there's no way we
can really help you and that sets people
away and that was a key innovation i
remember when we first talked of how you
architected the system you don't know my
ip address if i type in an adult search
if i type in
i have cancer uh if i type in i have
depression
there's no way for you to know
that this person jane doe john doe has
depression or was com you know
considering suicide whatever it is
those ip addresses are not there the
searches are not saved um so then i
guess that next uh begs the question how
do you make the search results better
because google's claim has always been
hey we we get that data and we can
tailor your searches and to a certain
extent that is true when i do a search
on
google they know that i've searched for
certain things before they're going to
surface them uh higher they know that
whatever if i'm into poker and i type in
a certain poker term maybe they'll
customize that to me right uh they
obviously know my location which i think
do you know people's location as well
because that's an important vector
yeah so um first of all like i
we've come a long way in search and our
search is used by mainstream people as
all the results you need we think the
quality is is on par um and partly
that's because most of what people think
they need from personalization is really
just localization like you said at the
end just like local results local
weather local restaurants that kind of
stuff we can do that in the same exact
way like your location gets sent across
automatically when you use the internet
and we just don't save any history of
that or really save location at all
but we can use it in that one search to
give you the information you need in
terms of good results the other thing
that's changed in the last 10 years in
terms of search is you know search is a
lot more than links nowadays it's got 20
different modules on it yes
yeah i got there just just couldn't
figure out the model and each of those
each of those modules now are big big
companies have vertical great data
sources there
um you know like say tripadvisor and
local and yelp that kind of thing and so
our
we work with those companies and we
think the aggregation of those can
actually be better than what google has
whereas google you know basically
decided to dominate and use their own
stuff in every category so they went to
google places instead of yelp
so if i type in ramen near me i will see
uh results that come i'll see apple maps
uh is your default maps partner i guess
and then uh i will see a bunch of places
that are provided for me by yelp i'm
assuming tripadvisor some obviously use
tripadvisor as you're doing yeah what's
the interesting about search is because
it's as you know it's all sorts of
different things we've had to
create a lot of search technology so
where we can get it with the best
partner we will but like for something
like local we've had to
do our own calling use apple use
tripadvisor use different things in
different countries you know how did you
make the difference how did you make the
decision to use tripadvisor not yelp uh
or make that a setting i can make how
did you come to that decision is that
just a partnership decision
or does yelp not agree with your privacy
concerns or do they want money how do
you come to that is it just a business
decision
yeah in each case it could be all the
above but it's generally trying to find
the best partner who's willing to kind
of work with us on privacy who also has
really good results um that's kind of
what it comes down to and then do you
get paid by tripadvisor for using theirs
uh and featuring them
each vertical's kind of different i mean
that local is different from sports or
or you know movies and because of the
way the data is and if it's a monopoly
in that situation you know all the
dynamics can change but generally you
know we have a lot of people coming to
duck deco so it's you know brands like
to work want to work with us because
we're we're showcasing their content got
it so all things being equal if
tripadvisor pays you more than yelp
that's a revenue stream for you
uh i mean it could be i mean our revenue
mainly comes from the regular contextual
ads we're
on these type of partnerships we're
focused on result quality so like we're
generally focused on making duckduckgo a
good search engine
before we get into the ad i